ride hailing service uber is searching
for a new leader we reported yesterday
that CEO and co-founder Travis kalanick
has stepped aside from his leadership
role his departure follows an
announcement last week that he was
taking a leave of absence in recent
months uber has faced sexual harassment
accusations and costly legal battles CBS
News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson is in Santa Barbara California
good morning good morning charlie
so the question is with lots of reports
what happened to him what led to his
downfall and did he resign or was he
pushed okay so lots of sources on this
one and they all confirm the same thing
the investors took control they were not
going to see the value of their
investment erode I am told it was a
tough conversation and at the end of the
day he was ultimately told they weren't
going to stop and he was convinced that
it was in the best interest of the
company for him to resign he's got a
huge stake in the success of the company
so huge stake so he reportedly owns 10%
of the company that's worth seven
billion dollars just to him the seventy
billion dollar valuation on this company
and he also continues to have a very
special class of voting shares where one
of his votes is ten times more powerful
than most of the people inside of the
boardroom and he will stay on the board
melody Sheryl Sandberg's name as you
know from Facebook keeps coming up what
are the chances as a possible
replacement what are the chances
realistically do you see that happening
and what does a company need right now
in a new leader so I talked to multiple
sources around Cheryl zero chance that
she's leaving Facebook zero but what I
am hearing from those involved in the
search they're looking for a CEO who has
some relationship and/or working
knowledge with Silicon Valley so I'm not
expecting to see an East Coast drop into
San Francisco they made it clear a lot
of people want this job but they also
made it clear that they see this job is
not one person but a team because they
have so much work to do and they have so
many open positions in the c-suite you
we mentioned melody that the investors
took control and specifically benchmark
the group there
we're the ones who went directly flying
to Chicago reportedly to sort of say hey
you got you got to go who are they
they're a firm in Silicon Valley
well-regarded
great reputation and they coalesced
reportedly a number of the other
investment investors including the big
mutual funds ient fidelity and they said
you know together these are the steps
that we're going to take what I
understand is they had planned ABC but
they only had to go with plan a just
last wheel here of Travis or will he
possibly later have a chance to come
back in some ways ICM is not leaving
since he's going to stay in that board
room so he will be an ongoing presence
inside of that company and I actually
think that that may be a good thing it
may be very important long-term for the
company because he understands it inside
and out and I would think whoever they
pick is going to have to get along with
Travis and see as you point out that a
presence yeah they have to understand
that's going to be hard that makes it
harder to recruit because you have that
founder still sitting across from you
and you may be second-guessed so you're
gonna have to hold your own in that room
all right Mellie it's a very interesting
story and certainly to be continued
thanks a lot an asset that's right
Apple's Steve Jobs and Twitter's Jack
Dorsey have come back we're out and then
they're back in Union so it can't happen